chuckles sing the tunnel backs up fans
in the pocket throws off the back foot
in the end zone better second sleeping
in front of the intended receiver the
forward jet parents Brooks another back
foot throw picked off by the Patriot
Sammy there you go a lot of fun right
there from from your guy right there no
lack baby I'm sure he never disrespect
Scott he's a lot
well done Scott we're playing the Fletch
theme because we were just monitoring
our Twitter feed all throughout our
night watching the game you got the
Daniel Jeremiah right around the middle
of the first quarter I thought this
would be a good game tonight I also
thought Fletch lives was better than
flesh alright there's lots to account
for from Monday Night Football my buddy
from the NFL media group and also one of
the radio voices of the Los Angeles
chargers locally here in Los Angeles
Daniel Jeremiah how are you DJ well
interesting football weekend for me rich
I've never never seen an ending to a
football game quite like the one I saw
in Asheville and then I thought well at
least you know he end up this football
weekend with a good Monday night game
with a scrappy Jets team it's gonna
really miss a ball game and halftime I
told my wife I'll go get my son all you
can stay here I don't seem to stay home
watch this no I I had all my children
around me and that also includes
Brockman and Dell 2fo they were all
there with me and my house watching it
together okay let's let's start first
things first here since I know you are a
huge Sam Donald guy that you get the
Fletch commented it's not the only
reason why I wanted to have you on the
show you are a huge Sam Donald guy are
you concerned based on what you saw last
night Daniel you know what's interesting
I watched tape this morning and you see
you know obviously the mechanical stuff
is Olek was you know having a little too
much fun with this but he was you know
he was thrown off his back foot a bunch
which he's done successfully at times
but that's a good reminder that he needs
to clean that stuff up I think that's
something he can fix there's protection
issues with this team
a couple of interceptions there's
miscommunication down the field so I I'm
I'm gonna step back a little bit and say
this is a Patriots thing more so than it
is a Jets thing and let's let's let Sam
Donald you know get some games if you
look at their schedule I think what a
better feel for him yeah four or five
weeks from now but man he looks so good
against the Cowboys and then this was by
far the worst effort of his career but
rich I was I was bored this morning so I
looked this up because I was thinking
about Bill Belichick and in the state of
New York though this year they've played
the Jets twice the bills and the Giants
the quarterbacks the starting
quarterback in those four games are 51
for 113 for 498 yards one touchdown 11
interceptions and 14 seconds this is
that good you know what Daniel it's it's
let's just put it this way subpar but
let's put Josh Allen and the bills aside
since the Bills almost did in fact get
the Patriots that day despite despite
you know not being able to learn all
right exactly
sticking on the darkness you you know
seeing it is a Patriots thing is still a
Jets thing because the Jets need to get
through the Patriots thing in order for
the Jets to become a thing that they
need to be with Sam darn 'old
in their midst I mean this is the
supposed crown jewel here and they are
not pronoun coach in to handle it and
now they have a new general manager with
whom you're very close with Joe Douglas
what do you think Joe Douglas is
thinking this morning can you give me a
little bit of his insight because there
has to be some sort of positive movement
otherwise there is a danger of darn 'old
regressing Daniel yeah no look and I
always want to point this out with Joe
and and I've known Jill for a long time
he's been a good friend there's no
better respect war and personnel than
Joe Douglas Jill took this job after the
draft so the roster you see on the field
right now there's not having Jill
Douglas his fingerprints on it
so he's going to get a chance to improve
this roster and you know somebody asked
me this the other day rich and I said
Joe needs to have
Noah's Ark offseason he needs to of
everything he needs to pass rushers two
tackles two corners I mean this roster
is not great and you saw it look what
Sam wasn't out there the team team
couldn't get a first down I mean it's
it's it's it's in terms of the gap
between them and the Patriots it's
significant but I do think that Joe
given you know a couple years here is
going to be able to get the pieces in
place and and really to me it starts
with the two tackles and getting to edge
rushers I think that's a glaring
weakness on this team right now
well then also I just wanted to spend
one more second on this year Daniel
it's the caretaking of it that's that's
what I'm saying is care taking of darn
'old where last year he's drafted and it
was a Deadman coaching in Todd Bowles
then they switched to Adam GaSe and now
we are five six games into this now and
I understand there was the mononucleosis
but the seeing ghosts aspect annual as I
say at the top of the show where that
Mike was caught
Sam Donald saying that I understand that
quarterbacks see ghosts again Bella
against Belichick defends all the time
and I understand young quarterbacks see
ghosts all the time the fact that the
Jets say yeah my cup my young
quarterback just two starts in from from
mononucleosis against the the Patriots
on national TV go for it where's the
protection for this kid where that's my
concern Daniel or is that am I am I
right or am I overreacting I give you
the floor I sent the text to somebody
last night on he remember who me
actually Curt was texting me a bunch
during the game he texted me like I
cannot believe this you know what you're
seeing with you know all the zero blitz
that you're saying and just well let
Curt speak for himself on that stuff but
this morning Agri forth go for it but
you know look it's it's it's something I
thought when they aired that with him
saying I'm seeing ghosts I'm not up on
on what the protocol is there I know
obviously with hard knocks you know Mack
you know stopped everything from from
getting
to get into the airwaves which which
upset a lot of viewers I guess but I
would imagine there's somebody in the PR
department that would have you know a
chance to look at what they're going to
blast out and if that is the case man
that is awful to let that that Cliff get
out because that's something as Jets
fans know like that you know like a but
fumble something that happens that that
that odd can stay with a player and
attached to a player throughout his in
his career and you can be sure if four
years from now Sam Donald has a four
interception game that that's going to
be all over social media about the
seeing ghosts that's going to stay with
him so I thought I looked from looking
at it from a personnel standpoint that
would really tick me off that that got
on the air
Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich Eisen
show let's flip the script here Daniel
how do you beat the Patriots who is
equipped to beat the Patriots DJ well
you're gonna have to you know see all
this man coverage so you better have the
weapons to scare them out of that a
little bit and you know all the zero
blood stuff that they're running you
know I still look at the Chiefs and I
know that they locked up the Chiefs for
a half before the Chiefs exploded arm I
think that's a type of team with those
type of weapons that you have to you
know hey you'd be a little bit cautious
you want to play that much you know
you know man man not even man free just
zero covered with nobody in the middle
of the field they'll help I don't know
that they've had a team that's really
challenged them with weapons like that
like the Chiefs could be able to do and
then you know Baltimore I think just
historically and being on the inside of
that a little bit there's you know so
most teams are a little intimidated by
the Patriots not only are the Ravens not
intimidated or have they ever been
intimidated by the Patriots they kind of
they kind of enjoy going against the New
England Patriots so that's a team that
that I think with that run game and the
way they do it which is so unique they
can give them a little bit of trouble
here
but you know I you look at their next
game against the Cleveland Browns if
they're right
if the Cleveland Browns are right now I
worry about their past protection
holding up but they have the people on
the outside that if they want to play
that coverage Baker will hit a couple of
those down the field because they've got
some players that can win one-on-one
and then defensively against Brady
clearly the self Scout has been very
well underway with Belichick with the
acquisition this morning for a second
rounder in next year's draft for Mohamed
Sanu what do you think that's all about
DJ well well I look at mom it's a new
Fitz and you know in so many different
ways first of all he's incredibly bright
so he's going to be able to pick this
offense up which is very difficult to do
in the middle of the season
he's great after the catch which as you
saw last night it is a death by a
million paper cuts passing attack so
he's gonna be able to you know take all
these underneath throws from Tom Brady
and fight compete for extra yards and
then I think his size once you get down
into the red zone area will help them
because you know they rely on trying to
run it in once they get down there he'll
give them a you know passing option
passing threat once they get down inside
he's so big and so physical I thought
this was a this is a perfect patriot
player for all the reasons that I just
mentioned but big physical tough smart
he checks all those boxes yeah you
forget he checks the Rutgers box to
Daniel that's correct you have the
Rutgers connection and you also have the
ability to throw the football which I'm
sure Belichick he might throw it to
Edelman who throws it back to him who
throws it to Brady I mean they might run
like a triple Lindy at some point DJ I
mean it's yeah it's just it's alright
that said do you think do you think
Gronk gets a call in this self scout for
New England as they I mean again
everyone's wondering why is New England
getting briquette gaming Brady reps and
Sony Michele reps and all these guys
reps with three minutes to go in a game
it's because Belichick views this is
crucial snaps to try and get the offense
on the same page if there's a problem
down the road or just think these guys
don't know Jacoby Meyers is out there
you know so that's that's to me it's a
non-stop self scalp is Gronk do you
think necessary for this team to win it
this year I don't I don't think you know
look
at the point where they've had so many
of these different runs where they've
missed this guy or that guy that I'm
beyond saying they need this one
particular person except for number 12
so I I don't think they need gras to go
win another championship but I could
also sit there and say okay this they
wake up and this team's 12 and OH
Gronk might want to just selfishly say
hey I'm gonna go ahead and attach myself
to a team that could actually run the
table and and see if you can finish it
this time so I would think that'd be
pretty appealing to grok to come back
and say I'm not gonna have that much
wear and tear on my body get the last
three or four games in and get into the
postseason and then see if I can hoist
the trophy and and be a part of
something really special with the team
that really does I mean you look at the
schedule and I know there's some tougher
games on the horizon but I I watch this
team play the way they're playing
defense rich I don't know what the
average is it can't be giving up ten
points a game like six or seven points a
game they're giving up right now so I
they're fully capable of making that
type of a run and if I'm Rob Gronkowski
before I you know get back to
Nickelodeon or wherever he's ever be
yeah could be a fun thing to attach
yourself to yeah the Patriots 18
interceptions this season already number
one total scoring defense in the NFL the
exact number six point nine points per
game that would be on pace to blow away
the Super Bowl era record before I let
you go DJ you referenced it at the top
you're the the color man if you will
along with Mad Money Smith local here in
Los Angeles for the Chargers what what
gives I essentially throw it wide open
to you about why is this team right now
at 2 & 5
well I mean start with the with the v
loss money had he had two of the best
game-winning calls that weren't game
when he goes you're never gonna hear one
was Eckler on a pass and one was Gordon
on a touchdown yeah I've never seen
anything quite like it man
but no I mean it's just been it's but
first of all you eat one injury after
another I think the one thing that stood
out to me the most is that as good as
you thought Derwin James was last year
you even have a greater appreciation
this year and I try and you know good
the good thing about doing these games
races it really does help me with the
draft prep and when I'm watching this
this team this year I made a note to
myself look you know Safety's you know
interceptions ball skills range you know
communication those are all kind of key
parts of being a good safety but if you
if you can't tackle if you're missing
tackles at that position it's going to
cost you touchdowns points and games and
they've missed that dude because you go
back and look at every big play they've
allowed this year usually there's some
kind of a missed tackle with the safety
position that's been huge and that's
that's on the defensive side of the ball
on the offensive side of the ball you
know just beat up up front
I think Melvin's holdout then coming
back in it was you know the wrong game
there's some disruption there and
haven't been able to find any type of a
rhythm but yeah it's been a it's been a
bizarre baffling season and then in the
NFC DJ the Saints with Teddy Bridgewater
going and winning five in a row with him
as a backup there six in one mark
matches Aaron Rodgers and the Packers
who have been tremendous but they're all
looking up if you will a half game
behind the still undefeated San
Francisco 49ers whose defensive linemen
defensive DeForest Buckner will be
joining me here in our number two the
best team in the NFC through seven weeks
would be who which well I'm sticking
I've been riding the 49ers train and I
know they don't have it all put together
yet offensively but if you have to give
up 21 points in a game and I think that
defensive line is special enough that
they can carry a football team and
that's not to take anything away from
Fred Warner
playing behind them Quan Alexander
they're good at the linebacker position
Jimmy ward Richard Sherman and company
are playing better than expected the
secondary was a question mark coming in
but they've been really good and I have
so much faith in Kyle Shanahan as a game
planner and in a play designer and the
way they get the run game going and
Garoppolo for whatever woes he's had
Richey doesn't lose he does not lose
football games with the 49ers so you
know I think the Saints that the Packers
the Vikings they're all you know it's
going to be a fun race in the NFC the
way they're all planned and I just think
that that D line for the for the 49ers
is one of the best we've seen in a long
long time so you're saying circle week
14 San Francisco in the Superdome you're
saying circle that baby in December how
sweet is that gonna be the NFC's it's
gonna be awesome man it is gonna be a
battle royale with the way all these
teams are playing ok well I know you're
doing your move the sticks pod today
right with Bucky you got that going on
today yeah ok yeah we've got that we've
got that going on I think we might get
spend some more time talking about this
jets situation not great not great Bob
again I'm genuinely concerned that darn
'old may may not make it Daniel
I really am and I'm not talking about
physically I'm talking about just as you
pointed out the whole seeing ghosts
thing that Belichick absolutely big be
clowned them undressed them last night
in front of the whole nation when
everybody's thinking okay they're all
back CJ Mosley's back I mean every
maneuver that was made by the Jets was
absolutely defrocked I can't come up
with a another word for it I'm genuinely
concerned that dartle may not be in the
right spot DJ well rich rich the you
know it sounds like the way we're kind
of describing is that he needs a you
know he's sick could be emotionally sick
and needs to go to the doctor and the
good news is that if you go see the
doctor and look what he prescribed it's
Jags dolphin Giants Redskins raiders
bengals dolphins so there's a lot of
there's a lot of healthy medicine in
that upcoming schedule hopefully he
takes it okay and and again before I go
let you go do you don't really think
Fletch lives is better than Fletch DJ do
you the Reverend
first of all the Reverend Jimmy Lee
Farnsworth is one of the great movie
iconic characters of all and I will I
will stand by that grade I'm gonna throw
the red challenge flag on your DJ but
it's okay it's okay I got that in my
sock like Bella check I'm throwing it on
the field thanks for the time as always
Daniel you're the best no problem just
remember one thing that's all ball
bearings edgy it's that and that's from
the original that's what I'm saying
it's the original isn't it I can't
remember they all blend together all
right DJ move the sticks on Twitter and
also on instagram follow Daniel Jeremiah
I do for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app